there's a tendency to think that
paparazzi are invading people's privacy
you know hiding in the bushes trying to
get some scandalous photo we're just out
here making a living just like every
other person
right now I want to get Victoria Beckham
she comes out just just before 9 o'clock
hopefully would be her there it usually
takes me only 20-30 minutes tops to get
out the door from when the second I wake
up so I live in New Jersey which is very
close to the city I absolutely love
taking the ferry it's the quickest
commute that there is you know it's as
picturesque a commute as there can be
but at the same time I'm in my zone I'm
reading all sorts of articles from the
day before so I went to NYU for
photojournalism one of the assignments
that I was giving in photo class was go
out and take a photo of somebody that
you don't know on the street and I ended
up getting a photo of Taylor Swift and
it was printed in People magazine so
instead of just you know handing in my
homework I handed the professor at
People magazine so I ended up dropping
out after my first semester and meeting
up with Cesar and we
one of the team it's been five years now
five years actually working together and
we formed this - screaming - for seven
times the mobile office has Wi-Fi
it's our hiding spot it's our vehicle
it's everything that we need all of our
work is done from that throughout the
day so right now we're gonna head over
to Victoria Beckham's hotel she's here
for Fashion Week Fashion Week is one of
the busiest weeks for us hopefully we
make it there in time I'm running a
little bit late
she's been clocked at nine o'clock every
morning for the past four days we got
here at 8:45 and dad today already Wow
so it looks like she's already out the
other photographers are already editing
their photos which means she's long gone
is she gone we have a saying that if
it's meant for us
then we're gonna get it so just brush it
off it's nothing serious all right
so we're gonna Mercer to check out who
is gonna be there so it's been a few
hours we wanted to get on the board we
haven't got any photos yet this morning
so we kind of want to go the easier
route we want to sit by a hotel where we
know there's people kendall jenner
staying here
kya gerber staying here every single
sometimes people are undercover at
sunglass
want to sit here for a little bit even
though there's other photographers which
we usually tend to stay away from I hate
working around these guys for every
photographer that shows up on a scene
the dollar amount gets sliced they all
are trying to get the same exact shot we
are the real ideal situation is to get
something that only you get kendall
Jenner for example an exclusive of her
can be a few hundred up to maybe a
thousand dollars 30 guys 20 guys they're
taking the same photos it's you hope to
make $50 we're gonna get some coffee and
move on to something that's probably
exclusive
so we're driving around and we spotted
some other paparazzi that were waiting
in front of one of the most popular
restaurants bar pity so we had an idea
that somebody was inside but we weren't
sure who so it could be either Hayley do
you happy or Bella Hadid the other
paparazzi were scared off by us showing
up it turns out that it's Chaya Gerber
one of the biggest up-and-coming models
daughter of Cindy Crawford
are you enjoying Fashion Week I
since she's up-and-coming and she's
wearing some great fashion this could be
a couple hundred dollars solid so our
upload process includes picking which
photos I like best quick crop depending
on the quality of the photo we can make
pennies or we can make five figures
kendall Jenner
it will be coming out I say three
minutes four minutes tops we got a phone
call that Kendall Jenner's car had just
pulled up at the Mercer we're only five
blocks away but in New York City traffic
that can be up to half an hour you guys
might have to go by foot I guess 104 it
[Music]
we're right right on time
got the shot we gotta compete against
all the rest of those guys so this has
got to go online right away we're
different from all the other
photographers we work as a team they're
gonna all fall off our book we got a
senator and it turns out we beat all the
other photographers to publication
we're on a roll man
[Music]
so we got a tip from a restaurant that
Bella Hadid had just came in
generally some of the most popular
clients that buy our stuff are the Daily
Mail people I'm so happy we caught that
stalker Bella for real if you need us
anytime we are here we're different from
other people because we value the
relationship in the long term we respect
them they respect us being the nice guys
goes a long way I have to say it's
[Music]
ariana grande is one of the celebrities
that we have worked with from the very
beginning before her career even began
in in music had some great moments with
her one of the best stories was the day
that Rihanna took me to the club for my
birthday but that's not Drake that's
miles
her favorite paparazzo Cesar sent her a
message letting her know that we were
out there and that it was my birthday so
she came downstairs wearing a huge red
heart she gave me a big hug said happy
birthday and said I'm gonna meet you
over at the club you're coming with us
we walked inside together and partied
for hours she bought me a very expensive
bottle of champagne just by being nice
we get some shots that nobody can get
tiffany tiffany get a shot right here
paparazzi is a term that is endearing to
me I think that it describes what we do
people look at paparazzi on the street
and they automatically assume negative
things about us we're just out here
making a living just like every other
person we don't do anything that's
against the law most of the people that
come to New York are doing press anyway
good can you talk to me about how much
money you guys are is it does it has to
be a more specific than six figures
let's talk about why I'm uncomfortable
first we don't really like to you know
speak about what we make because it
though it's different than what other
people make in this industry we've set
our goal of trying to make a million
dollars a year and I think it's
something that we're gonna achieve very
simple job well done completed
good day time we got a little bit of
sleep let's start all over tomorrow
let's go
[Music]